ALWAYS.
LAWRENCE, THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
PROGRAM.
SINGLE UNELECTED FEDERAL
JUDGE SUDDENLY IN CHARGE OF
THE COUNTRY'S ENTIRE
IMMIGRATION POLICY SOMEHOW.
DOJ IS FIGHTING THAT.
NEW AND FASCINATING STATS
TONIGHT ON IMMIGRATION LEGAL
AND ILLEGAL AND HOW IT
INTERSECKETSD WITH CRIME IN
RELEASED TODAY, AMERICA'S
TERROR THREAT IS CLEARLY,
AMONG OTHER THINGS, AN
OF TERROR OFFENSES BETWEEN
9/11 AND THE END OF 2016,
FULLY 73% WERE IMMIGRANTS.
MANY OF THEM ENTERED THIS
COUNTRY DRY THROUGH CHAIN
IMMIGRANTS HERE WITHOUT
SOCIETY AND CLEARLY MANY ARE
20 PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY
ARE MURDERED EVERY YEAR IN
HONOR KILLINGS MOSTLY FAMILY
MEMBERS SEE THEM AS TOO
WESTERNIZED.
1500 ARE PUT INTO FORCED
MARRIAGES IN THIS COUNTRY
ANNUALLY.
STATES COMMITTED ABOUT
WE SHUT DOWN IMATION.
THEY DO DEMAND HONEST
DISCUSSION.
NOT DISMISSIVE ACCUSATIONS
OF BIGOTRY EVERY TIME
DOZENS OF TIMES SHUT UP DUMB
AMERICA ILLEGAL AMERICANS
ARE WAY MORE LAW ABIDING
THAN YOU ARE.
TAKE AS CLOSE LOOK HOW
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION AFFECTED
CRIME IN ONE STATE ARIZONA.
THE NUMBERS ARE STARK.
IN THE STATE OF ARIZONA,
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ARE MORE
THAN TWO AND A HALF TIMES
THEY ARE ALMOST THREE TIMES
AGAINST CHILDREN AS WELL AS
ARMED ROBBERY.
CONVICTED ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
45% MORE LIKELY TO BE GANG
MEMBERS.
OVERALL YOUNG ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS BREAK THE LAW AND
NOT JUST IMMIGRATION LAW THE
REST OF THE LAWS AT TWICE
THE RATE OF AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
IMMIGRATION IS DIRECTLY
LINKED TO HIGHER CRIME
RATES.
THESE NUMBERS DESERVE HONEST
DISCUSSION IN THE HALLS OF
POWER.
IMLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ARE
FUTURE MEDAL OF HONOR
RECIPIENTS.
THE FACT WE DON'T WANT TO
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION SAYS
EVERYTHING ABOUT THE
PRIFORTS.
ATTORNEY JEFF SESSIONS
SOUGHT RELEASE AND HE JOINS
US TONIGHT.
>> Tucker: IT DOES GIVE NEW
NUMBERS TO THE IMMIGRATION
NUMBER OF EFFORTS IN I THINK
2006, 2007, 2013 TO SCUTTLE
ATTEMPT AT AM NEST CITY
DURING THAT TIME I REMEMBER
YOU SAYING THE WASHINGTON
ESTABLISHMENT SUPPORTS ANY
WHAT DID YOU MEAN BY THAT?
>> THAT'S EXACTLY CORRECT.
THAT YOU CLAIM YOU ARE
AFRAID TO GO HOME AND GET TO
PROVIDE SUBIS
PROVIDE SUBSIDIES TO PEOPLE
THE MORE YOU GET OF
SOMETHING.
THESE KIND OF FAILED
POLICIES ARE NEVER GOING TO
WORK.
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
DON'T BELIEVE IN IT.
AND WE HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
REFORM IT AND EVERY TIME YOU
COME UP WITH A REFORM THAT
WORKS, GETS BLOCKED.
AND SO PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
SAID WE NEED -- WE HAVE
IMMIGRATION.
WE WANT IMMIGRATION.
BUT WE WANT TO VET THESE
PEOPLE.
WE WANT TO KNOW WHO THEY ARE
AND MAKE SURE THEY ARE GOING
TO BE PRODUCTIVE PEOPLE.
PEOPLE WHO ARE FLOURISH IN
AMERICA, WHO ARE GOING TO
NOT BE TERRORISTS, NOT BE
CRIMINALS.
AND THAT'S EXACTLY CORRECT
FOR AMERICA.
IT'S JUST UNBELIEVABLE TO ME
THAT WE HAVE THE RESISTANCE
WE ARE HAVING TODAY TO THE
REFORMS THAT ARE ON THE
REFORMS THAT WILL ACTUALLY
VOTED FOR.
>> BIG ISSUE IN THIS
ELECTION.
TRUMP TOOK IT DIRECTLY TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IT WAS A HUGE FACTOR IN HIS
VICTORY.
BEFORE IS STILL TRYING TO
SCUTTLE GOOD REFORMS TODAY.
>> Tucker: APPARENTLY HERE
ARE FEATURES OF THE PROPOSAL
WE ARE NOW LOOKING AT.
IT WOULD FUND ABOUT 10% OF
THE PROPOSED BORDER WALL
ABOUT 70 MILES OUT OF 2,000.
NO ENFORCEMENT BASICALLY
CAN'T DEPORT ANYBODY.
EXPAND CHAIN MIGRATION.
MAKES DIVERSITY LOTTERY MORE
UNSKILLED.
IT DID DOESN'T SEEM LIKE
IT'S MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
PROPOSAL THAT HAS ANY
PROSPECT OF SUCCESS.
THEY NEED TO LOOK AT THE
PROPOSAL AT HOUSE JUDICIARY
CITY CONGRESSMAN GOODLATTE
HAS PROPOSED IT WILL WORK.
END ILLEGALITY.
END PROCESS ILLEGALITY AND
MAKE THE SYSTEM WORK BETTER.
THAT'S WHAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WANT.
TALKED, ABOUT THOSE ARE
POEHLERS THAT FAVOR
ILLEGALITY.
THEY SUBSIDIZE ILLEGALITY.
THEY ENCOURAGE ILLEGALITY.
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE SICK OF
THAT IT'S TIME TO END IT.
THE CHOICE IS CLEAR AND IT'S
GOING TO BE EVEN CLEARER
THIS YEAR.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE SOME
VOTES IN CONGRESS.
PEOPLE NEED TO BE HELD TO
ACCOUNT OR YOU ARE GOING TO
FIX THIS SYSTEM, CREATE A
SYSTEM THAT PROTECTS AMERICA
ARRESTED FOR TERRORISM CAME
HERE WERE BORN ABROAD.
SO IF THEY HAD BEEN PROPERLY
SCREENED AND REJECTED, WE
WOULDN'T HAVE HAD THESE
ATTACKS IN OUR COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: SOMEONE I SPOKE
TO WITH DIRECT KNOWLEDGE
SAID IN HIS MEETING ON
IMMIGRATION LYNDELLE IS I
GRAHAM SUMMED UP HIS
ARGUMENT BY CITING A POEM
FROM THE STATUE OF LIBERTY.
NOT REALLY A CASE YOU WOULD
EXPECT FOR REPUBLICANS TO BE
MAKING.
WHY AREN'T THERE MORE ARTIC
COULD YOU SAY LAT REPUBLICAN
MEMBERS OF THE CONGRESS
MAKINGS CASE THAT YOU JUST
WE ARE NOT AGAINST
IMMIGRATION.
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT AGAINST
WHAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WANTS HAVE A RIGHT TO, AND
WHAT'S GOOD FOR AMERICA IS A
LAWFUL SYSTEM OF
IMMIGRATION.
AND WHEN WE ADMIT PEOPLE TO
OUR COUNTRY, WE SHOULD BE
LIKE CANADA.
WE SHOULD EVALUATE THEM AND
MAKE SURE THEY ARE GOING TO
THEY HAVE THE EDUCATION AND
SKILL LEVEL TO PROSPER IN
AMERICA.
THAT'S GOOD FOR THEM AND
GOOD FOR AMERICA.
WHAT GOOD DOES IT DO TO
BRING IN SOMEBODY WHO IS
ILLITERATE IN THEIR OWN
COUNTRY, HAS NO SKILLS AND
IS GOING TO STRUGGLE IN OUR
COUNTRY AND NOT BE
NATION SHOULD DO.
AND WE NEED TO GET AWAY FROM
IT.
A GOOD DEBATE NEEDS TO BE
HAPPENING THIS YEAR.
THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT ON
THE LOTTERY.
THAT'S RIDICULOUS.
HOW ABSURD IS THAT FOR A
POLICY FOR A GREAT NATION.
WE NEED TO TIGHTEN UP ON OUR
ADMISSION OF PEOPLE FROM
DANGEROUS AREAS OF THE GLOBE
WHERE WE CAN'T VET.
WHERE WE HAVE HIGH NUMBERS
OF TERRORISTS THAT LIVE IN
THOSE AREAS.
WE SHOULD CERTAINLY BE MORE
CAREFUL AND LIMIT THAT KIND
OF KILLING CONGRATULATION.